bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono famigerati siamo su
fei che un gioco molto molto molto
carino l'ho visto non l'ho visto lì
screen pro parla di questo qua che
incredibilmente fa mondo riconoscono per
strada e deve sopravvivere
quindi tipo io posso spingere i fan via
ok ma posso fare i salti volendo ok
aspetta ma cos'è ma cos'è hold sell pt
che idea per fare per fare una foto ma
più di tanto va bene va bene cosa mi
sono presentato solo nudo pick up york
lo so posso mettermi vestiti let's roll
perfetto ecco la mia limousine arrivo io
esco la limosino dove entra c dove entra
devo arrivarci il mio obiettivo è
raggiungere la mia di musico di mia
gente dentro william paparazzi don
l'eden tech px chiude in quanto del suo
nipote loro voglia distruggere la mia
reputazione quindi non fare foto con
loro ok sono quelli paparazzi va bene
let's golf o una macchina fotografica
anch'io che non è forte non ho capito la
società oddio non ho visto i fan mi
hanno visto meno visto web ad ora su ciò
che è troppo realistico ragazzi
incredibile ti guarda corrono senza
guardare dove fanno sono incredibili no
no no ci si rifarà io voglio tocchi
sarei fan basta
porca vacca mi sembra di essere in
centro il duomo a milano
selphy faccio semplici ragazzi si eccoci
qua ragazzi questo ciò che non è
realistico perché in realtà non puoi mai
fare foto con gruppi di persone
devi farli singolarmente e con i loro
cellulari quindi è molto più difficile
di così dalla realtà ve lo assicuro cioè
ci sono 60 persone
non è che fa il ciak e scompaiono si
debba tener noko demonio ci sono i
paparazzi arca vacca sono cerchiato celo
celo sono i rossi abbiamo fatto delle
foto i paparazzi mi hanno rovinato la
carriera
semplicemente perché hanno fatto una
foto 2 sono venuto male non mi taggate
nelle foto teste di milia via facile
foto ma porca vacca al terremoto sono
famoso nell'acqua salve signor marò
abbassa lei non mi può conoscere ai fa
jogging maledizione quanto succede ma
cosa ma cosa avete orientato platform ma
in tutto questo
3 quei tre cuori pepe niente non ho
capito però va bene tutto questo dovrà
aggiungere la mia limousine che che
lontanissima perché ho fatto un giro
allucinante
let's go nord e di farne possono causare
dei terremoti
a unique chiamo william bon james va
bene a farmi perfetto la via li usino la
prendo più comunque stai attento alle
fan girl loro sono sono pazze e non ti
lasceranno solo se ti prendono madonna
quanto è vero ma anche sono fortissime
non ti lasciano proprio so ti seguono
quindi lo posso farmi in self dio mi
suicido mi suicido piuttosto una volta è
successo che una mise via gemito ea una
ragazza era dall'altra parte della
strada io ero sul marciapiede non stavo
camminando li stava camminando
dall'altra parte della strada sul suo
marciapiede e guardava verso di me non
sta guardando dove stava andando quindi
faceva tipo così a un certo punto sento
fortissima
lei si è schiantata contro un palo giuro
su dio è successo veramente io ero
dall'altra parte la sua è stata una cosa
molto kringe mai successo sul serio ma
bastava bye bye bye a casa tua
manager chiamano ce l'hai una famiglia
l'ho buttata via vai dai cori lo scudo
di una porca vai a casa tua con un
rischio a farla cadere in tutto ciò ok
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatto ciò però mai
lei e le due posso togliermi i vestiti
che non lo sa e per distrarre i fan mi
chiama se questo non ho mai provato lo
stesso qualcuno vorrei vorrei ben i
vestiti però non penso sia una cosa
producendo non è il massimo dorica mente
ma i fan non sanno saltare questo è
risaputo la gara forse perché non è
visibile posso fare i celti vai andate
sui vestiti correte più distratti
porca vacca il suicidio oddio oddio mi
sono aggrappato sul fenomeno lo era
viani businnes mi piace una fanger per
terra
aiuto dov'è allora devo ritornare cosa
sta succedendo laggiù dove non si scappa
con una macchina in corsa
perfetto questa perfetto cela fanger ma
inizia la bagarre
che rimasta lì ferma a trovare la fonte
organiche ed è pigra però una fender
tira ma porca di quella bacca porca c'è
pure la m pure la m ma va anche a
curvato come la supera la m c'è il
macchinista la metro che un mio fan un
attore modo lo chiamano l'ascensore ci
mette pure del tempo a scendere
maledizione di saper giocare a metà li
ama paparazzi aiuto buche non ho
veramente capito come fare i denti
perché si sa fino a new york sopra la m
la domanda red ste che senso ha
ciao william sono circondato dai
paparazzi ma lo devi prof
scrive su twitter devi prenderti cura
dei tuoi fans ma cosa proprio mentre
stavo per arrivare dopo tutto sto
bordello del sentato pia aiuto faycel
fico 10 pan
ma cosa dovrebbe essere nome di papà i
sensi come li fa fare
domani fa paris elfi ci sto provando non
me li fa fare
ok adesso aveva fatto non mi fa fare più
ma perché non ride mai
vabbè ma faccio fuori se cosa che non li
pace ma c'è temime nudo in un parco che
corro sta roba perché serve rullino
capirla eccoci qua
perfetto e tu lo facciamo senti contesto
che bisogno di un rullino per ricaricare
la mia macchina fotografica però non lo
trovo fatevi trovare trovo un rullino
devo trovare un minino non lo posso che
se non trovo il rollino lo facciamo una
foto porco demonio che una polaroid tra
l'altro c'è un aspetto trovare un lui
eccolo macchina fotografica
eccolo il free to one l'estero perfetto
86 persone che si accalcano i paparazzi
che hanno circondato il mio agente
quindi si appresta a porta
gli agenti è stato circondato ma non so
come come faccio corri come che parlano
questi scusami no no no no non posso
fare foto con voi non posso fare poi
scusate ci sono i paparazzi i ragazzi
qualcuno ha visto il mio manager lorenzo
ci sono striscioni così ne parlerò e
porca vacca elfi
bene allora quanto sono contenti avere
sensi perfetto va bene allora 48 i miei
pantaloni tutto ciò che sarebbe molto
forse senza i miei vestiti perdo vita
non ne sono sicuro però la veste sono in
una piscina ma basta anche la gente in
una fontana pubblica
porca vacca quanta gente ma basta andate
là step ok aiuto
selphy molto bene poi alle balle se non
mi avvicino al cosa non ha senso non
parte il timer 57 secondi già from my
aiuto
c'è da dire che è fantastico perché lo
ha detto a scendere nel salire le scale
tipo aldo ace elfi ok non ho capito se
fanno un servizo la fanno governo la fa
togliere di mezzo sì però non so
cosa fare ci ha fatto mai fatto s'è
tolta di mezzo anche la fang aiuto e fa
bene perché lo cerchiamo l'economia york
aiuto a ragazzi avete mai fatto
ecco che lo so ma voi avete fatto foto
con me in pubblico così gente che si
accalcava e una domanda seria nel caso
commentate qua sotto e spiegate quanto è
realissimo visto di velocità per la
minaccia al capri a fuori dalle balle
per uscire fuori dalle balle
le fan che sono io non solo di non sono
ancora io sono ancora vivo non sono
fermi non sono ancora di no cervi e
basta ce l'ho fatta mi piacciono
veramente troppo diramati circondata
sprinta ok mi sono tolto di tutta l'erba
incredibile incredibile
non so ma ho fatto con uno di vita
fantastico questa è la vita che mi
rimane quando esco in corso abbiamo
fatta dov'è il mio manager porco il
demonio il mio manager
cosa ti pago affare dato i vestiti di
nero potuto di sony che si chiami quindi
prima verso di vita e oltre buzz
lightyear va bene dove stiamo andando e
stata non solo anche vedendo sono tipo
jokic in tutta gioco ci sono chiano rips
va bene spero che i giocatori non siano
i miei fan perché placarli non sarà al
massimo
dove devo andare in tutto ciò non li
abbiamo già doppiato a distanza perché
il parma ha l'occhio lungo e ragazzi
ricordatevi eccolo eccolo il mio manager
e il mio manager manager vieni con
portami a casa ce l'ho fatta oddio credo
sia una delle idee più geniali per un
indie da quando da quando faccio video
comunque spero che vi sia piaciuto
iscrivetevi a canale se mi vedete per
strada chiede mi senti se siete fan girl
non mi rallentate per favore però i
sensi li facciamo lo stesso portate il
ruolino mi raccomando eh eh bella
ragazza
[Musica]